good morning John you may have noticed
that my glasses keep falling off my face
so I'm at the mall and I was hoping if
at all possible
people could help me decide on a pair of
glasses because I've loved these but
they are irreparably wacky bent out of
shape fallen off my head from benefit 5
and then you're gonna vote on which one
I should get if you remember that's what
I did I rejoined with these glasses some
4 years ago I did well that time so I
trust you to not make a really horrible
decision but before we get to the voting
I have something very important to
discuss with you cup stack sorry I
should have said Sport Stacking
because that is the official name of the
sport in which you stack cups Alex day
stop don't fall
since Alex doesn't have a poster he said
in his recent video that people could
just put his vinyl album up on the wall
so that's what I did back to Sports
stacking
now I've watched a lot of Sport Stacking
videos on YouTube I imagine if you spend
any time on YouTube you've watched them
as well those two kind of visceral
reactions that one has upon watching for
example world record-holder Steven
frigging on 14 years old stack cups
really fast one just legitimately that's
crazy that's just that's amazing that's
a physically amazing feat and the second
is inevitably why so I find cup stacking
weird but really weird think about
finding it weird is that it's kind of
weird that we find it weird you follow
me on that one so strange to us to think
that a 14 year old child would spend you
know significant hours like tens of
hours a week developing cup stacking
skill but it's not strange to us at all
to think that a job would spend a lot of
time developing like kicking balls into
net skills or throwing balls through
hoop skills or knocking balls into holes
far away with blob skills I'm just
rambling now but sports I think by
definition are useless activities like
if they were useful they wouldn't be
sports whether you're knocking down pins
or throwing balls or stacking cups that
there's no like objective reason to be
doing those things value is placed upon
those things by mutual agreement of a
group of people whether that group of
people is several hundred cups stackers
or 30 million people watching the Super
Bowl ekta vyg rement it was where almost
all value comes from there I'd be some
value that's genetic that like we like
love and family that that kind of value
that's not a collective agreement that's
just something that's in us but
everything else if not it's not
ejected Lee valuable we value it because
we've come together as a group of people
to value it cup stacking to me points
this out because it's so new and it's so
peculiar that the first reaction that
everyone has is what why would someone
spend time doing that but that's the
question why do we spend time doing
anything it's because we and the people
that we care about the people in our
communities get excited about ideas and
we do them together and it's fun I am
kind of worried that Sports acting is
kind of coming to an end because there
may just not be any way to get any
better than Steven krugen on already is
so whatever a community created sports
TAC and it drove people to do amazing
things and the community that created
Sport Stacking cuz as far ii created
that community and the guy who
popularized was a frickin PE teacher and
now he runs like a four million dollar a
year sports tacking business that's just
really impressive me you could count the
number of PE teachers who turned their
PE career into million-dollar businesses
on like one like one finger so that is
why I think Sport Stacking is pretty
cool and very nerdy and now we must move
on to pick my glasses so here they are
you have these ones we have these ones
we have these ones we have these ones
and we have these ones and now's your
chance to click you will be taken to a
video and the view count for that video
will be the absolute score for those
glasses so if you watch all of them your
vote doesn't count so don't do that
just watch the one or ones that you like
the best and then I'm gonna buy those
and then I'm gonna wear them for like
ever so don't screw it up I'll be able
to stop pushing my glasses up every
three seconds which for the people who
who seem to rejoice in counting the
number of glasses push-ups that I do in
a video I know that will be sad for you
but for the rest of you hopefully you'll
be happy John I'll see you on Friday